marines are pretty amazing as a culture
the officer says you do that and the
marine just does it there is no question
asked and there's no push back this is
not the time for well i'd like to share
my ideas in high stress we need we need
command and control it's actually very
very important but it's done so with the
absolute undying belief that you're
making decisions with what you believe
is the best interest of the organization
the mission whatever it is and i accept
that sometimes you'll make mistakes and
that in in the case of combat could cost
people's lives and i accept that because
i believe that you still have the best
interests of this organization more than
yourself you're not sending me to harm's
way you're not leveraging the trust and
and the command
for personal gain you're doing it for
the gain of us